this is omens new sultan Haytham ban
tariq al saeed sworn in a few hours
after the death of his predecessor
sultan qaboos the oldest ruling monarch
in the region and the founding father of
modern day oh man sultan - made it clear
in his first speech to the public that
he will follow in the footsteps of the
late sultan we remain guided by the late
Sultan's wisdom going forward we will
preserve and embark on the achievements
he made this is what we are adamant to
do to follow in his footsteps with
respect to international relations
we will follow in the same course set
out by the late Sultan we will embrace
foreign policies based on peaceful
coexistence without any interference in
domestic affairs of other states the
succession ceremony was swift and smooth
dispelling any concerns about
uncertainty and instability in one of
the oldest dynasties in the Gulf region
the new Sultan will have several roles
he is the prime minister controls the
government the Armed Forces finance and
foreign affairs his biggest challenge is
balancing a budget that relies on
revenues from dwindling gas and oil
resources the death of Sultan Qaboos
comes at a critical moment tension has
grown in the region after the u.s.
assassination of Iranian military
commander Qasem Soleimani
his killing has shattered any hopes of a
diplomatic solution no man has in the
past played a crucial role in narrowing
differences between the two rivals it
has a long-standing neutral approach to
the problems of the region in 2017 when
Saudi Arabia the UAE Egypt and Bahrain
imposed a blockade or utter o man
refused to take sides calling instead
for dialogue it also plays a central
role in the international efforts and
the war in Yemen
the new sultan has insisted he will
maintain his nations neutrality and
honor the legacy of sultan qaboos the
late ruler came to power in 1970 at a
time when a man was underdeveloped
divided and facing a rebellion in the
South but caboose managed to overcome
those obstacles and turn it into a
modern state caboose faced another
challenge in 2011 when thousands of
people protested demanding better wages
and more jobs as the Arab Spring was
spreading Sultan Qaboos fired members of
his government gave more powers to the
consultative council and began reforming
the public sector the late one arc will
be remembered by his people as a
unifying figure and by the world as a
shrewd politician who turned a small
nation into a regional player Hashim
Espada al Jazeera